you have 30 seconds
[Laughter]
okay hey guys it's katie and jasmine and
we are back with another episode of
awesome translation if you haven't been
here before we take a recipe and put it
into google translate it goes from
english to korean to italian to apricons
and many many more until finally back to
english to give us this hilariously
translated recipe last time nemo got a
little bit sassy with me
so you guessed it it's her turn to be in
the hot seat i think she's scared she
should be let's go give her the recipe
okay let's do it
okay you ready mimo yes
fruit juice mama
[Laughter]
sounds easy let's get started you seem
so scared i am honestly i'm so scared
you're my friend
step one fill the cave at 350. link the
document was the selected page
branded 50 oven page i think parchment
paper oh oh wow fill the cave at
the document is the baking equipment
whatever it is wow how are you feeling
right now so confident we're gonna line
this beautiful container
i'm just doing this i'm doing it i'm
going to cut my parchment to fit in
there i've decided i'm going to turn my
oven on to 350 degrees and i'm going to
line this baking pan with a parchment
are we making a brownie
but that doesn't have any fruit my pan
is ready i'm gonna go turn my oven on to
350 degrees
where's the oven step number two put a
two tablespoon oil for mixing in a large
bowl and ignite
add salad and cry for three to four
minutes
okay
[Laughter]
a night like start i need a large bowl
i'm thinking
where's my stand mixer or my hand mixer
let me check oh
this is the only thing i can start
ignite means like electric to me is that
what it means to you guys
am i so off our opinion doesn't matter
never mattered to
me my question is two tablespoon of oil
is
stupid
what do you think you're making that two
tablespoons of oil is stupid
you have 30 seconds
oh chicken i see a bunch of greens
i'm making a marinade
i'm not gonna add any of the greens i'm
gonna actually use an herb parsley and
i'm gonna blend it three to four minutes
can you do all crying
two tablespoon of olive oil there's
vegetable oil but i just love olive oil
ignite
i've never been this confused in my life
why is kelly crying i'm supposed to be
crying i have to be the mom of this girl
i'm not kidding i'm crying
so i'm done crying
now that i'm done crying and my marinade
is perfect i'm gonna move to step three
transport receive and cool then squeeze
too much water and chop all right
it's getting worse
apparently i wasn't supposed to ignite
it
i need a tip i need kelly can we have a
powwow yeah all right let's go
out just a minute
sometimes there's ingredients that need
excess water removed
but who is fruit mama
excess water removed think i think um
[Music]
that was not helpful kelly kitty
disappointed
part of me really thinks i should like
blanch
spinach and like remove the water and
chop it up
everybody smile if you think i'm right
cool means it was heated ignitement
turned on a stovetop
so i'm thinking i'm going to blanch some
spinach bring out the excess water
chop it up and add it to my big bowl for
big mama so our water is hot and we're
gonna add as much spinach as the gods
tell me i'm not all of it spinach is
like one of those things that becomes
nothing when you cook it squeeze too
much water
now that our excess water is removed i'm
gonna chop it up i don't feel great but
i don't feel bad i think that's all
right i'll dump it in here do you think
spinach was right um
i'll get back to you step four place the
half teaspoon sliced nuts half cup
parmesan yes spinach was right one and a
half cup cheese two fine garlic quarter
cup chopped celery quarter cup chopped
pickle
one lemon flavor okay maybe spinach
one
huge chicken and low
what's saline rotate until rotated and
great okay i'm honestly not gonna
overthink it i'm gonna add half a
teaspoon of sliced nuts half a cup
parmesan i mean there's parmesan i'm
committed half a cup of parmesan one and
a half cup of cheese
i think it needs like some creamy cheese
there's feta we're gonna go for
italian cheese garlic oh you see garlic
keeps going garlic oh yeah i keep
forgetting it could be wrong i'm used to
reading recipe and knowing
i trust them yeah it's garlic that's for
sure garlic i think i'm gonna follow
everything as it tastes i don't have
trust issues you have seen this show
before right a quarter cup of chopped
celery this is the only questionable
thing in this recipe so far the pickle
also makes no sense to me i know that
one for sure is not pickled green onions
artichoke artichoke it is i just feel
like pickle marinade just seems like
artichoke here's some lemon juice we're
gonna mix this i feel like fruit juice
mama needs to be renamed to something
else because i'm not adding any fruit to
this
salinas salt where's my chicken
so this chicken is already cooked i'm
gonna be adding one whole chicken i'm
gonna remove all the bones and shred the
chicken and add it to my spinach mixture
step five put the pillow on the desk
with a long face grease two inch short
and add another leaf on top to cover the
two leaves okay i think pillow means
some sort of dough
okay here
are my pillow options pie puff pastry or
phyllo
this looks like a pillow going with puff
pastry i feel like i finally like make
sense the only thing i'm still
questioning is the celery
i am putting my pillow on the work
surface the dust so i'm gonna separate
my dough i think long face means it's
telling me which direction to put it i'm
gonna roll this out a little bit
oh
make a long when you roll it i think i
need a tip and i need my tip from
jasmine and i want it to be generous
oh
okay your hint is
you need more leaves
[Laughter]
that means i need more dough i think i
need to roll this and cut it and then
it'll give me more leaves so grease two
inches short and add another leaf on top
to cover the top the two leaves huh we
have more than two you told me i need
more than two i had two okay i've rolled
out all my dough and now i'm gonna
grease it and attach the two leaves
together like a sandwich everything i'm
doing feels correct i'm gonna read step
six cover me in oil and add two more
leaves and put
each other upstairs as before grease me
again
and add two more leaves
repeat with grease yeah it's just
stacking it i'm gonna like add this
fill it
grease it and then add more yeah oh my
gosh if i figure this out on my first
try jasmine i'm coming for you
we're gonna start stacking it to
upstairs use about one third of the
salad cheese mixture on the tip but one
inch limit surprise into
sausage where did the sausage come from
and also where's the fruit juice
we're gonna go ahead and layer all these
like step six said and then i will put
one third of the filling on top oh my
gosh this is not gonna be great oh was i
supposed to roll it after putting butter
in between and like make it thin
i'm gonna use one third of this mixture
and i'm gonna put it in here but like
leave one inch for the crust to like
oh do you think sausage had anything
sausage i think it just means encasing
it
was i supposed to roll it into sausage
and like then like
there's a few things i could have done
different but at the end it's gonna be
delicious but this is crust to filling
ratios off
step number eight the shape is now
changing to a screw and then add the
dough to the prepared baking sheet
bestow was a moist veil i'm pretty sure
i was supposed to like leave the thing
out and roll it into a sausage and then
like make this circle i know for a fact
i can't go back huh so we're gonna skip
step eight and go to step nine because
there's nothing i can do about it right
now repeat the above steps twice more
and insert the beginning of each circle
into the front end to form a large
circle i knew it was supposed to be a
sausage
we got it wrong we
i really want to dump it and like start
again actually we don't okay what are
you doing so confused
okay wish me luck i'm gonna make this
into a sausage and i'm gonna roll it
into a circle and then i'm gonna put it
in the baking pan okay it's gonna work
there's a wheel there's a way i am
filling one third of the mixture into
each two leaf dough and then rolling it
up and then it's gonna make a giant
sausage now i'm using
way more of my filling than i would have
used the other way so like this makes so
much sense it's gonna make a circle guys
wash the baby with egg and decorate with
question mark okay egg wash the baby is
clearly this it said question mark and
it just means whatever you want
i'm still confused where the fruit comes
and i feel like you should still have a
clue i would like to use my last clue
there's the name of a thing inside a
fruit
that you could decorate with oh pit
have you decorated a lot of pits oh
seed oh sesame seed i'm gonna egg wash
it and decorate it with some sort of
seed now we're gonna top it and decorate
with sesame seeds we're gonna use both
black and white sesame seeds for color
purposes step 11 bake the cake for about
45 minutes before baking
i think it's oh oh oh it's saying bake
the cake for 45 minutes before eating
but that turned into baking
all right i'm gonna go put this in the
oven for 45 minutes the second baking i
think means
cooling and then i'm going to let it
cool for a little bit all right it's out
of the oven
it smells so good i'm excited confidence
level 10 again step number 12. take a
moment before serving
okay
can you please take a moment
okay i followed directions i did not
think fruit juice mama would look
anything like this i'm ready to see the
final dish
closed eyes open um
it's the same thing
mine is just like big juice mama this
one is just
fruit mama i'm gonna try mine first can
you hear it like perfect
that's really good i'm not kidding it's
like spinach dipping and pastry though i
kind of think i messed up the chicken
part love it love it love it
okay now let's try the real deal so the
dish is called spenacopta and it's a
greek dish it's not always in the spiral
design but this time we chose to do that
and it's a spinach and cheese filo dough
pastry don't see any chicken so that's
red
hmm
flag
herbs in this one it's so good i think
they're like distant cousins
you guys want to come try it this yeah
cheers
oh my
god so what was huge chicken egg egg
so good right thank you wow this was so
much fun i had no idea how hard it was
being in front of the camera and not
knowing like the next step and stuff
like that but honestly i feel like i did
pretty well you did great sweetie
this was so much fun but let's get
jasmine back on the hot seat thank you
so much for watching and if you have any
recipe ideas send it to katie at old
ladykitty on instagram bye
you